so we told you a lot on this show about
the potential dangers of big tax some of
those dangers are imminent and their
technological and the main one is
robotics and artificial intelligence
remarkably the person the political
figure who is making the most sense on
this subject was thought about it most
deeply is a Democrat who is running for
president he's Andrew yang he's an
entrepreneur
and as we said he's a Democratic
presidential candidate he says that
artificial intelligence and expanded
automation could potentially cause
violence in this country and that we
need to do something about it right now
Andrea he joins us tonight thanks very
much for coming on and I meant that with
sincerity I haven't heard anybody in our
political conversation describe the
threat as clearly and compellingly as
you have why should we be worried about
automation well if you look at the
backdrop we automated away four million
manufacturing jobs in Michigan Ohio
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Missouri and
those communities have never recovered
where if you look at the numbers half of
the workers left the workforce and never
worked again and then half of that group
filed for disability now what happened
to the manufacturing workers is now
going to happen to the truck drivers
retail workers call centers fast-food
workers and on and on through the
economy as we evolved in technology
marginalizes the labor of more and more
Americans what will be the effects of
that do you I mean that's that's a
massive displacement of people what will
happen once that happens well as you
said I think it's going to be disastrous
where if you look at truck drivers alone
being a trucker is the most common job
in 29 states they're three and a half
million truck drivers in this country
and my friends in Silicon Valley are
working on trucks that can drive
themselves because that's where the
money is well we can save tens even
hundreds of billions of dollars by
trying to automate that job but I was
just with truck drivers in Iowa last
week and imagining that community
recovering from their income going from
let's call it 50 thousand dollars a year
to much much less than that catastrophic
Lee it's going to be a disaster for many
many American communities you're the
only people I've ever met who's honest
about the effects of deindustrialization
I remember in Washington the idea was
they'll all become computer programmers
and so everything is fine but that
didn't happen my question is do we have
to sit passively back and let this
happen to the country well that's why
I'm running for president Tucker is I
think it would be insane to just sit
back and watch this automation wave
overtake our communities and our economy
so we're not ostriches we can get our
heads up out of the sand and say look we
get it artificial intelligence is real
self-driving cars and trucks are being
tested on the highways right now and we
need to evolve we need to actually start
pushing the way we think of economic
progress to include how our families are
doing how our children are doing and
things that would actually matter to the
American people because GDP is gonna
leave lead us off a cliff
you know robot trucks great for GDP
terrible for many many American
communities so we need to get with the
program and figure out how to actually
make this economy work for people I just
I I sent with my job open I agree with
you so strongly let me ask you finally
why isn't this a central question in the
campaign of everybody running for
president on any side and why instead of
they talking about issues that really
are kind of frivolous why don't they
talk about this you know it's a good
question Tucker I mean one of the
reasons I'm running for president is to
push this into the center of the
mainstream agenda where every candidate
should be talking about what we're going
to do about the fact that we're
automating away the most common jobs in
the economy right now as we're sitting
here together the labor force
participation rate in the United States
is 63.2%
the same level as Ecuador in Costa Rica
and if anyone thinks that's where
America ought to be I mean that number
is even going to be further challenged
when all this technology comes online so
we have to make America
embrace this challenge of the 21st
century and then try and address it
together as a people last question
shouldn't people who cite unemployment
statistics be penalized for saying
something so stupid you know we have a
series of bad numbers and I referred to
these P is one certainly a headline
unemployment rate is completely
misleading and one of my mandates as
president is I'm going to update the
numbers they actually make sense the
amounts yes because we can know what's
going on otherwise you can't make wise
decisions yeah right now again and you
know this our life expectancy has
declined for the last three years first
time in a hundred years because of a
surge in suicides and drug overdoses how
can you say an economy is healthy when
our people are dying in my
I don't even know what you think on the
other issues and I and I just support
what you said so much I appreciate your
coming on Thank You Tucker it's great to
be here thank you